what's up everyone i'm chef joe sasto
and today i'm going to show you how i
use this 500 year old torkio to make a
delicious bowl of pasta and as a bonus
i'm going to give you a madeira cream
sauce recipe that you can use on
anything now let's get to it
i got my bag of tricks here so we have
here a torkio this is a solid bronze
piece of machinery used to make pasta
16th century this is over hundreds of
years old and how they used to make all
of those extruded shapes of pasta that
you're used to eating every single day
we also have our handle this is going to
allow us to clamp onto the top and apply
pressure
and our dye these come in all different
shapes and sizes and they're
interchangeable so depending on which
one you have in there will determine
what shape of pasta that you end up
making i'm excited to show you how to
use this thing but before we get into
that i've got to show you how to make
some pasta
dough we have a finely ground ramasanata
semolina durum flour we're using all egg
yolks for this one i have a finely
ground double zero white flour and then
i have a coarsely ground semolina flour
a little bit of salt and then we'll just
start by doing this all in the stand
mixer you could do this all by hand but
i do like taking some shortcuts when i
can we're going to get all of our flours
into the mixer first our derm flour then
our double zero
finally our semolina
and a little bit of salt we're gonna
give this a quick mix and we can go with
all of our egg yolks at once and we're
just gonna let this rip
[Music]
now you'll notice this dough is going to
be a little different than some other
pasta doughs you made out there it's
going to be harder a little more dense
and we're going to add just enough water
to allow it to come together so just a
few sprays at a time i'm using a very
old piece of equipment to make the pasta
but i'm using a very modern piece of
equipment to make the dough i like just
combining those two different worlds
together we're getting very close here
we can see that it's gotten a little
more sticky here i'm able to squeeze it
into my hands and it holds together this
is exactly where i want it to be we're
going to leave it just like this and
we're going to bring it together right
on the counter squeezing this all
together now if you didn't have a
machine this is what the entire process
would look like and i'm purposely
forming this into a cylinder so that way
it's easier to load into our machine
so our dough is ready to go this just
needs to rest i like to do that in a
vacuum sealed bag a lot of pasta chefs
look down on using a vacuum sealer with
their pasta dough i do not i like taking
this extra step here it force hydrates
the dough and speeds up the resting
process so we're just going to take our
dough log
we will slide it into our bag
and then right into our vacuum machine
like magic
so we have our dough here for hydrating
resting we're just going to set this
aside to rest and set up our ancient
pasta gadget are you ready for this
so we have all of our pieces here to our
pots to gadget our torkio starting with
our main frame here so what we want to
do first is put on our die in this case
i always like to leave my dyes submerged
in water especially when i had used them
before so that way the pasta doesn't dry
on the inside today i'm going to show
you how to make gargati think of it
almost as like a thicker spaghetti or a
thinner penne we'll drop that here into
our screw
attach that to the bottom then we just
want to clamp this onto our table
sometimes you need to get a little
creative figuring out how and where
you're going to clamp it i like to use
the seed clamps that i have here
and we'll just go under the table
and the other one
all right we are secure last thing here
we have our handle this will go right on
top and we can open it up and the dough
is going to go right to that tube
so we have our gadget assembled time to
load it with our dough
this has been resting only about 20 30
minutes not very long at all
if you didn't have a vacuum bag you
probably want to let this rest one to
two hours or so so it really makes a big
difference and speeds up the entire
process
i'm probably going to split this up into
two batches
down into here
we'll just slide that in
we'll throw this on top
attach our handle then you just want to
get it started up no i'm kidding it's
not electric we're gonna go right down
starting to turn this
and
this is your workout for the day
so you'll tell right when you get to the
end it's not going to turn anymore the
moment of truth
you can take all of your pasta and
ribbons
bring them right up
line them up and lay them onto your work
surface now we just open it back up
and we can load in our second piece of
dough
slide that down so what i really like
about this particular shape the gargotti
is that there is actually a small hole
forming through the center of each of
these noodles and it has this super
unique mouthfeel when you bite into it
that i absolutely love all right so
that's done
at that
beautiful
we'll come in with a little bit of
semolina flour here so they don't stick
together
now they have beautiful texture on the
exterior here that's going to help grip
our sauce provide wonderful mouth feel
so we'll allow it to dry for just a few
minutes before cutting them and that's
going to keep that hole right through
the center of the pasta i usually go
about an inch and a half
i feel like that gives you real nice
texture
and length all the way across
not too long not too short but at the
same time you cut these into small
little macaroni
or you can leave them in really long
noodles so just depending on how you're
feeling you can have a whole variety of
pasta just from this one die i got a
tray here
dusted with just a little bit of
semolina i'm gonna keep them separated
now i'll get started on our madeira
cream sauce
so we have some cream we have thyme
peppercorns some sliced shallots and
madeira which is a fortified wine it
kind of tastes like sherry or port and
then a little bit of vegetable oil to
get us started so in my sauce pot here
to get things going we're just going to
start heating up our induction burner
a little bit of vegetable oil down on
the bottom then we'll come in with our
sliced shallots we want a little bit of
sweating we want a little bit of
sauteing so we got a little bit of
action going on here in our pan
shallots are sweating down we're not
really looking for color here
in this case i really like some black
peppercorns and then as much or as
little time as you have
today i have a lot of time you know if
you're short on time don't be afraid you
can put a little bit of time
we're just going to let that soften the
peppercorns just toast up oh it starts
to get very fragrant aromatic our
madeira deglazed with our wine
and we don't need to worry about cooking
off that alcohol immediately because
we're going to add our cream and let
that reduce during the time
our time is going to infuse
you'd always legalize a little bit of
lemon juice works very well so our sauce
base is reduced by about half here we'll
just come in here and strain this
we have our infused cream here that's
gonna be our sauce base let's cook some
pasta
we're gonna go a little bit of salt in
our pasta water
i'm gonna take a moment here just to let
everyone know your pasta water should
never be as salty as the sea it should
taste like water soup a well-seasoned
stock we're gonna take all of our pasta
now go down into our water
bring this back up to a boil throw the
lid on for that so it's been about two
minutes do a little taste test here
careful it's hot don't burn yourself
one color all the way through you can
still see that hole right in the center
let's bring these guys out
i like using a spider we'll go into a
saute pan bringing a little bit of that
pasta water with us noodles back on the
heat here
now we can come in with our madeira
cream sauce so what we want to do here
is marry the noodle and the sauce
together we're going to go a little bit
of butter here
we just want to emulsify that butter in
i always like to come in with another
splash of raw madeira so that way you
have a little bit of that cooked off
madeira flavor a little bit of that raw
madeira flavor coming through
some fresh cracked black pepper
and then we're just going to swirl this
together
to emulsify
we'll see this start to thicken up
reach into your pocket and find yourself
a tasting spoon
don't burn your mouth love that
i'm gonna kill the heat
let that carry over i have a nice big
chunk of parmigiano reggiano cheese i'm
going to grate on top this is going to
add a nice bit of saltiness
it's delicious nice big spoonful of our
pasta
look at that
we have some black truffle we're going
to grate on top of course if you don't
have truffle or you're not into trouble
you can skip this step but i happen to
love it
truffle madeira cream gargati baby my
friends look at that time for a taste
test reach into your other pocket
find yourself a golden fork come in a
little bit of everything
rich creamy satisfying you call it old
reliable and even if you don't have this
gadget you could still use the sauce on
any type of pasta that you have don't
forget to tag me when you make it at
chef.joe.sasto thanks for watching
[Music]
you